it is of course time for the press
preview first look at the front pages as
they arrive
over the remainder of the hour we'll be
taking a look at what's making the
headlines
with the director of the british foreign
policy group sophia gaston
and the communications advisor and
former aide to boris johnson
guito hari to them in just a moment but
let's take you through at the front
pages that we have starting with the
metro
and according to that paper a third of
uk adults have now had
both doses of a covered vaccine
the telegraph warning though that 300
000 people have missed
urgent checks for cancer which could
spark another crisis in the nhs as the
pandemic winds down
the dentist will see you in three years
the daily mail leading with nhs waiting
times
the financial times reports on the
belarusian government forcing a ryanair
flight to devote
and land in minsk all so that it could
arrest a prominent
opposition activist
staggering statistic this at just 1.6
of rape cases leads to charges being
brought
that's the lead story for the guardian
and as previously mentioned we're joined
tonight uh by sophia gaston and ketu
hari
lovely to see the both of you um and
this this story uh saphir that we're
going to start with this evening on the
front of the ft
and i imagine it will be creeping up in
in lots of the other papers as well
belarus forcing a flight to land in
minsk by
scrambling a mig-29 i mean you can make
this stuff up
it's absolutely bonkers i mean this is a
flight that was an eu flight so going
from
athens um in greece uh to lithuania so
two eu capitals um and this is
an eu-owned company ryanair and this was
just an
ordinary passenger flight these were
people
you know going home to see family or
going for a weekend holiday
um but on this flight you had a an
opposition activist to the really brutal
belarus regime and what happened is as
soon as the flight gets over belarus
airspace
there's essentially a foiled uh bomb
threat
and essentially they force the pilots to
land make an emergency landing escorted
by a
belarusian plane um and essentially
they stop on the tarmac and arrest this
activist and uh it's just caused
extraordinary drama in the eu as you can
imagine and
i mean it's it's just a really um
shocking
scene and i think everybody's aware that
this activist who's been
pulled off the plane uh is facing pretty
serious consequences
he's being arrested he could face the
death penalty just another example of
this regime really
cracking down but it's a really tough
test for the eu because this is so
brazen
it involves civilians you know real real
just ordinary people whose lives are at
risk
um and i think it's going to be tests
for the eu to come together can they be
a credible foreign policy actor can they
get all their voices all their
institutions in lockstep with a clear
message here
um so i think the next 24 hours are
critical for that
um but the world is watching on yeah i
mean gato i i survey is a
alluding to you know pan european
condemnation of it we wait to see what
that
what that turns into but of course when
i spoke with them the the chairman of
the foreign
uh foreign affairs select committee tom
tougan had a little bit earlier on he
made the point look lookachenko has not
acted
without you know some fairly significant
approval
uh from moscow we do know that vladimir
putin will have
had at least had her eyes on this
operation
yeah it's extremely sobering in a sign
of just how dangerous our world is
and how the rule of law is not something
you can take for granted even in
somewhere like this that is essentially
you know on
on the on the fringes of where we are in
fact you know as sophia was saying it
sort of involves eu citizens flying from
one
eu city to another so what started off
like the sort of plot of the
long-awaited bond movie that some of us
are still desperate to see and wondering
when it's going to come out
turns into something extremely serious
that makes us all
worried just when you thought that the
only issue with flying was was
covet and you know green and amber zones
and all that you've got this
and the possibility of being downed and
escorted by a military plane
uh because somebody on your plane is
undesirable as far as one of the
most undesirable regimes in the world is
concerned serious implications according
to the the foreign sector we will see
what those those will turn out to be and
sophia let's i just want to give our
viewers to two papers in fact because
they are related stories the front of
the metro
at their story they're celebrating the
success of the vaccination rollout you
know one in three have now had
both their jags which is incredible but
then of course you turn to the daily
telegraph and yeah dominic cummings pops
up once again talking about
you know the government's strategy at
the time but let's start with it with
the vaccination rule
this is an achievement it is something
to be welcomed and it is the way that we
are going to get
normality or some form of it at some
point in the future
the vaccine remains the good news story
and i think you know what the uk
government really hopes is the happy
ending or at least a sort of happy
interlude in
after a pretty difficult 2020. um the
news is that now a third
of uk adults have been double jabbed so
uh on their way to being fully protected
which is just an extraordinary
logistical feat
and i think we should all be really
proud of our institutions for
for delivering that um and also for the
british people
i think it shows real really strong
foundations of
community and social trust that everyone
said yes
you know we've we've had a a pretty
difficult five years
everyone's been at each other's throats
but we've come together and i think
i think britain's feeling a bit more
united as a nation now and his
vaccination program
has been really integral to that um but
i do think you know
we have to um obviously still be a bit
careful that we've had this indian
variant
um on our shores and uh it's had
everyone rather nervous
the last few weeks so i think it has
been erased against time with the
vaccination program we've got to get
everyone jabbed
as quickly as possible the latest data
that
has come out of the weekend shows that
the vaccines are effective so it's just
really important that we get um
as many jabs and as many arms as
possible but
um i think you know we've been so
trained
to see these cases going up and just
have that real sense of fear and
foreboding
um because of what happened last year
and we kept thinking oh gosh other
another lock down on the horizon
the vaccine is a game changer and i
think it's just going to take us a
little while to get our heads around
that
it certainly is and take us to the
telegraph though and dominic cummings
and perhaps you might be able to explain
to me exactly
what on earth he's trying to achieve i
mean he he talks about you know herd
immunity being at the heart of the
government strategy
pretty patel was the latest in a long
line of cabinet ministers to deny that's
the case i mean i know it's late in a
sunday and i'm a bit daff but i remember
patrick valenz
standing at the the lectern in dining
street directly referencing
herds immunity as part of this
government strategy what was coming up
to
yeah and i i've spoken to people you
know over the last
uh few weeks about dominic cummings and
what he's up to
and uh one or two have said to me that
he was the one and you can imagine this
from the kind of guy he was
he is uh that is captivated by the idea
of herd immunity it's eccentric it's
wild it's sort of counterintuitive
it sort of involves doing something
hugely controversial and he had to be
weaned off this idea is what a couple of
people have told me but he's doing the
opposite of course
just when the vaccine uh program really
is going gangbusters and i've been doing
a little bit of
volunteering as a vaccinator myself
pleased to say i understand
people in the arm the other day um just
when the last battle wins the war
he's trying to drag it back to the grim
start and
throw mud and try and bring down you
know prime minister that he was once
supposedly loyal to but he's now clearly
bent on trying to sort of destroy him
completely
um sophia though the front of the daily
mail i understand
that some people particularly in in
whitehall
want to have this public inquiry not now
just at some point in the future you
know it's in augustine to look forward
you must first look back and we have
some real problems in the health service
at the moment as the daily mail makes it
clear
some patients are being forced to wait
as much as
three years for an appointment
yes well it's sort of it's almost like
there's just been this enormous storm
and what will be coming on the other
side is just sort of
those sort of strange eerie days after
you've had a big storm and sort of
there's branches everywhere and
everything's a bit displaced and then it
all comes into
into a sort of clarity from from the
clear
skies and i think that's essentially
what we're
going to be entering i mean it's there's
going to be a lot of detritus around
that a lot of things
a lot of problems that were emerging
during the pandemic that we just
couldn't see when we're in the storm
and all of that's going to come into
view now and obviously
our health system is going to be one you
know really front and center of that
because
of course everything was done to create
as much space and capacity
in the nhs as possible to deal with this
really deadly and frightening pandemic
um but of course there are many other
ways in which people are
suffering or or you know new
uh different things emerging that will
need to be looked at and treated
and i think a lot of that has been sort
of swept under the carpet people haven't
had their minds on those other types of
health
it's really difficult to get
appointments so a lot of people are just
put off and what we know is that when
you put barriers
um to accessing the health system like
that there's a whole slaves of people
who just sort of fall through the cracks
and that's really what they're warning
here you've got a lot of
really senior people in in the medical
profession essentially coming out and
saying
there's this silent invisible crisis
that's been happening
um and if we're not careful um things
like dentistry
cancer diagnoses these are sorts of
things that we could just be
missing and of course we know there
could be some pretty
significant consequences for that down
the track so we need to get ourselves
back
on the road we're at before um but
that's going to require
everybody sort of getting over this
mental hurdle of
accessing the health service you know i
think i think there needs to be a
message coming out now saying look
we're through the worst of it we're open
for business please come back
and and start seeing your gp and start
uh you know looking over and making sure
that you're checking for those signs
because i think people just haven't had
the capacity to do that
um but we just have to sort of make the
case now
that we're in moving into a new era and
those things are really important
to see your gp so if you're lucky enough
to be able to get an appointment um guys
we have to pause them
and take a quick break but after
afterwards a story that's very close to
my heart
in vino veritas we'll tell you why
australian winemakers
are hoping for a post-brexit trade deal
at their offer a drink we'll see after
this
[Music]
[Applause]
i think one of the things that we've all
realized during this pandemic is how
important our well-being and our mental
health is now of course it's important
to separate
mental illness from well-being and
health and but i think all of us have
wanted to
take control i think and do a bit more
to look after ourselves ultimately and
you know whether that's getting outside
more often uh catching some natural
light exercising
uh communicating with those that we hold
dear and making sure we're managing our
stress effectively we're sleeping well
all these things play a part into
how we feel and so you know that's why i
wrote the book live well every day i
wanted to kind of bring
the science out there my personal
experience and my professional
experience and put that together into
i guess key chapters that people
hopefully can can use to improve their
own
health and ultimately feel feel better
from it i think it's
it's been different for everyone
everyone is different everyone's an
individual
and i think the pandemic in whatever way
has put pressure on everyone whether
you're on the front line working in
in a e or you're working as a carer or
whether you're at home
shielding and you know and there's so
many people that have
felt so much stress and pressure for
different reasons or isolation
and it's impacted everyone you know and
if you look at um even you know the
road map at the moment people going back
you know coming out of this pandemic
some people are really wanting to rush
back to
busy shops and get going again others
are much more cautious and
i think it's i think this pandemic has
really really taught us to listen to the
way we feel
and do things in the way that we're
comfortable uh uh
to do especially going back to you know
normality you know take things at your
own
time and look after yourself i really
really really hope that a lot of things
we've learned from this pandemic about
self-care
about investing in yourself and your own
time your own energy
will take that forward after the
pandemic because a lot of us been burned
the candle
at both ends far too long
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast for wherever you
are welcome to the safety rage
podcast for the ones who want to know
more welcome to the all-out politics
podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
my name's ella i'm an environmental
activist and founder of the
end period plastic campaign you might be
thinking why period products
what's so bad about them they're the
fifth most common item
found polluting europe's beaches they're
more commonly found
than straws or coffee cups
[Music]
welcome back to the press preview sophia
and geeto continuing to take you through
the papers
okay so let's let let's come to you
first uh this quarter
the front of the ft uh a positive story
for for for some people
australian vineyards thinking that this
fta might actually
that might actually do quite well for
them
yes and it's lovely to see a picture
like that and it does make you feel sort
of thirsty doesn't it
and it does help focus uh the mind as
well
because um there are huge benefits
potentially to a trade deal that
liberates trade
and and this is a very stark one would
you like to drink very decent australian
shiraz for less than it cost you at the
moment the answer for most people is
yes but this is all part of a really
really complex
elaborate trade-off of course that's
being negotiated
and if you then say but if we um
actually pay less for their wine
we'll pay less for their lamb as well
and if we pay less for their lamb will
we ever buy
great welsh slam ever again now i think
you should be able
uh to compete with things that are being
flown halfway across the world not to
mention that
carbon footprint that should be
off-putting for most people but it is
difficult and there are big big judgment
calls to be made
right at the heart of number 10 at the
moment that but that actually bring out
the
contradictions within the prime minister
himself not to mention the cabinet
between those who feel that you have to
protect certain industries
uh in in in the uk uh and and those who
think well
it's tough you know we we don't do what
we used to do 20 years ago 100 years ago
200 years ago
we've moved on to do other things
because other people in other parts of
the world can do what we used to do more
cheaply so
that's how trade tends to work it's a
painful process
but this is showing you one of the
potential upsides yeah i mean
sofia the headline glass half full i
mean anyone who knows me or indeed works
with me
who will tell you that i'm very much of
the opposite variety but i do tend to
enjoy pairing a nice australian shiraz
with a slab of scottish beef and i'm
afraid there are
aspects of the domestic economy that are
going to suffer
as a result of this steel armor
well yes i mean i think it's funny
because
the australia trade deal was meant to be
very easy i think there was a sense that
you know these are friends and
like-minded partners
uh they're close allies uh we share many
of the same interests and values but
there are
distinctions and uh you know i i
have lived in australia i have family
there and uh
i can tell you even just things like
farming practices
environmental standards the sort of
significance that's placed on
animal welfare they're just quite
different uh here in the uk
and uh so even when you're dealing with
some of your closest partners
um these sort of roadblocks come along
now you know i i will join you in uh
being rather enthusiastic at the idea
that we could buy
very good australian wine uh more
cheaply it is rather expensive over here
um but i think that this is one of those
cases where you just have to make sure
that you look at
things in the round and put the right
safeguards in place i mean
everything now every aspect of openness
i think we're sort of having to balance
a bit off with security
and that's partly a response to this
idea that you know maybe we had gone
sort of no holds barred into uh into
globalization and
and not really thought about some of the
asymmetrical costs and benefits so
i think you know we just need to be
careful that we're striking the right
balance here but
uh i think you'll be hard pressed to
find uh many people who'd be
upset about the idea of cheaper
australian wine